avec nous pour en parler pierre tattevin
infectiologues chef du service des
maladies infectieuses au chu de rennes
bonsoir pierre elle vient ainsi d'être
avec nous à vos côtés ricardo carbajal
chef du service des urgences aux
urgences pédiatriques de l'hôpital
armand trousseau à paris bon soir
ricardo carbajal merci d'être avec nous
donc pour les 12 16 ans l agence
européenne du médicament a déjà donné
son feu vert le 28 mai l'académie de
médecine elle la préconisent pour
l'instant pour atteindre l'immunité vous
partager cette analyse pierre tattevin
vacciner les plus jeunes pour atteindre
cette immunité collective après laquelle
nous courons oui on a bien vu depuis un
an et demi qu'on court après cette
épidémie qu'on n'a pas eu beaucoup de
succès avec les masques avec les tester
votre reportage d'entre eux mêmes c'est
pas simple on a maintenant des vaccins
qui marche très bien qui sont bénéfiques
pour les gens qui sont vaccinées mais
aussi pour la collectivité en limitant
la propagation du virus donc je suis
très favorable à ces propositions
ricardo carbajal vous êtes pédiatre
c'est votre spécialisé pareil favorable
sans réserve à la vaccination des plus
jeunes
absolument je suis totalement d'accord
avec cette proposition
je pense que il faut voir le problème
non seulement sur les faits dès
protection directe vis-à-vis de la
maladie des enfants parce que là on
pourrait dire que cette maladie n'est
pas très sévère chez la plupart
d'enfants on pourrait trouver c'est
dingue comment la rue m'ont pas très
fort mais je pense que et ses visions
doit être beaucoup plus large parce que
les enfants subissent des conséquences
non seulement de la maladie mais de
toutes les conséquences au psychosocial
que cet écartement des enfants des
écoles des privations des contacts avec
leur famille avec les proches
on traîne par cette épidémie et n'est
pas vacciné vingt 120 100 % de la
population parce que ce sont les moins
de 18 ans tout commence à faire la
saison même s'il fait 15% va être un
frein majeur à l'éradication
alors regardons carbajal vous êtes
plutôt à contre courant par rapport
à vos amis confrères de la société
française de pédiatrie ce nous propose
de les écouter
lakovic 19 chez l'enfant et le plus
souvent asymptomatique
les enfants sont peu contagieux et très
peu de formes sévères ont été décrites
même pour ceux atteints de pathologies
chroniques
actuellement il n'y a que très peu de
données d'efficacité et de tolérance de
ces vaccins disponibles chez l'enfant
à ce jour cette vaccination n'apparaît
pas comme nécessaire chez l'enfant en
population générale
ça c'est vrai que c'est quand même la
société française de pédiatrie qui le
dit a diet deux idées là dedans et ça on
le savait souvent asymptomatique peu
contagieux et des données d'efficacité
tolérance de ces vaccins pas vraiment
disponible pour le moment pierre
tattevin qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
répondre à ce genre d'argument de la
part de deux connaisseurs tout de même
oui alors il ya aucun doute sur
l'expertisé les bourgs isolement la
société française de pédiatrie je pense
que leur position va évoluer
il ya moins deux choses à dire c'est
qu'on sait que les variants au fil du
temps ont été de plus en plus mauvais
pour les enfants même si c'est pas comme
chez les adultes âgés mais c'est quand
même la troisième vague a été plus plus
marquée chez les enfants et puis la
deuxième chose c'est qu'on commence à
avoir ses données que la société
française de pédiatrie souhaiterait
avoir sur l'efficacité des vaccins chez
les enfants il ya eu des études chez les
adolescents avec pfizer avec modern
assez des vaccins qui sont moins
embêtant chez les sujets jeunes que
ponctuellement astrazeneca ne se voit
pas trop de raisons de rester arc bouté
sur cette position
ricardo carbajal quand on entend ça vos
piètres pédiatre vous n'êtes pas
d'accord avec ce qu'elle ferme cette
société française de pédiatrie c'est que
en gros il n'y a pas de danger
sur les enfants concernant ce virus et
en plus on a peut être donné
on parle là du bénéfice risque qui
s'inverse un petit peu par rapport aux
adultes
je pense que l'inconnue de cette
épidémie depuis mars 2020 et bien malin
celui qui a un avis péremptoire qui
changent pas la semaine suivante au
début de la crise on a changé trois fois
par jour donc en fait on fait avec
l'information que nous recueillons au
fur et à mesure ce qui vient dire de mon
confrère à l'instant effectivement il ya
des articles publiés dans les grandes
revues et nuit une glande autre revue
très renommé qui vient démontrer
l'efficacité la sécurité avec les
informations dont on dispose des ces
vaccins chez les 12-15 ans avec une
efficacité pour les façades qui a été
détruite la des 100 pour cent donc en
effet tim o na c'est lé mandat de
l'efficacité certains nous n'avons pas
encore des milliers et des milliers des
patients mais dans les patients qui ont
été inclus dans un étudiant qui vient
d'être publié il n'y a pas d'effets
secondaires majeurs mais je pense que
c'est tentant de penser simplement que
si la maladie n'est pas grave
chez ces populations là il n'y a pas
nécessité de se pencher de deux vaccins
ciblant à ce moment là on pourra dire
une chose de la roja nouveau journal
pour la plupart d'enfants n'est pas une
maladie grave mais tu des grands et les
adultes et sont la vaccination des
enfants
bah on ne serait pas au stade des
contentions de là et cette maladie là et
dans l'histoire de la médecine
pathologie infectieuse ça a toujours été
le cas donc je pense que à partir du
moment nous avons les doses suffisantes
et le calendrier possible il faut les
vaccinés est à mon sens je dirais même
plus ce n'est pas attendre d'avoir
terminé avec un âge donné pour commencer
des enfants parce qu'il faut être
pratico-pratique nous arrivons dans la
période estivale les vaccinations mois
d'autres servent très compliqué et nous
allons nous retrouver si nous ne mettons
pas en oeuvre une politique assez active
probablement avec un début des
vaccinations septembre en tôle et au
premier cas des décors navires us dont
une école va on va fermer les
conséquences psychosociales sont
dramatiques elles sont réelles
l'exclusion des enfants de ces milieux
là on va les payer pendant des années et
des années
est ce qu ont assez de recul tout de
même pierre tattevin parce que ça
concerne et ces données qui sont peu
disponibles
les experts n'ont étudié n'a été étudié
que pendant 55 jours
ces études d'homologation c'est quand
même peu qu'est ce que vous allez
répondre à ses parents prudent et
parfois récalcitrants et forcément c'est
logique quand on veut protéger ses
enfants jusqu'à 12 ans mais actuellement
il faut vraiment expliquer et expliquer
honnêtement ce que nous dit est vrai
c'est que comme si les vaccins qu'on n'a
pas depuis très longtemps dans paris
normalement de recul donc il faut
expliquer aux parents et je pense qu'il
faut faire comme avec les adultes c'est
à dire lorsqu'on attaque est disponible
pour vous on vous conseille de le faire
et quand on sent qu'il ya une opposition
franche sur leurs dix mois et on va pas
insister plus que ça ça a été la
politique de début c'est de proposer les
vaccins au maximum de personnes c'est
d'avoir la meilleure couverture
vaccinale possible et ça plutôt bien
crier juste ici on s'envoie population
de plus en plus clairement et ricardo
cabanas est ce qu'on est dans une
vaccination altruiste on vaccine pour
les autres pour le bien de la
collectivité en partie en partie parce
que ça fait partie de la chaîne mais
comment je le dis tout à l'heure en fait
les enfants ont un bénéfice si on arrive
à endiguer cette épidémie plus vite plus
les enfants auront des bénéfices donc
les bénéfices ne sont pas qu'un direct
c'est pas simplement un twist c'est pas
simplement pour n'est pas contaminé par
rim amis et que voilà il ya cette
maladie qui est bien grave chez certains
indiquent également chez les écrits
psychosociaux sont importants et un âge
qui est celle de l'enfance on a besoin
des vivres des choses qui peuvent être
vécus seulement à cet âge là n'iront pas
un livre plus tard donc c'est pas
simplement triste c'est aussi pour
contribuer à endiguer l'épidémie les
plus vite possible
effectivement je vous propose d'écouter
arnaud fontanet p
logistec institut pasteur et membre du
conseil scientifique qui nous donne un
argument qui va dans votre sens
messieurs écouter projetons nous à
l'automne à ce moment là comme une
grande partie des adultes auront été
protégé les collèges et les lycées
deviendront les principaux lieux de
circulation du virus
il suffirait que des variants encore
plus contagieux entre dans le jeu pour
qu'on connaisse de nouvelles tensions
dans les hôpitaux
ce ne serait pas forcément une quatrième
vague mais le risque de devoir fermer
des établissements scolaires ressurgir
et pierre tattevin ça c'est vrai que
c'est un c'est un argument parce que je
pense que les enfants n'ont pas
forcément bien vécu toutes ces
fermetures de classes
d'une certaine manière il faudrait la
rendre là je sauve car l'an 1 pas
puisqu'on se demande aussi c'est bien de
vacciner mais là est ce qu'il faudrait
la rendent obligatoire selon vous est-ce
que ça risque d'arriver c'est toujours
préférable de réussir à expliquer aux
gens que c'est bénéfique parce que c'est
vers ce que vivent nos collections et
bénéfique pour les enfants et puis pour
la population générale est pour
l'instant comme on a de toute façon pas
des stocks infinie on arrive à
progresser en proposant le vaccin à un
maximum de gens et donc maintenant
lorsqu'on est vers les adolescents
ceux qui sont intéressés on leva le ce1
ils sont contents les autres que les
regards de tous et s'aperçoivent que
finalement ça se passe plutôt bien
et progressivement ça fait tâche d'huile
on arrive à augmenter la couverture
vaccinale je suis pas très favorable à
l'obligation de monsieur carbajal vous
parliez tout à l'heure des variants qui
pourrait être plus contagieux peut
peut-être plus dangereux vous n'avez pas
prononcé ce mot pour les enfants mais il
ya tout de même ce ce spectre sans
agiter le chiffon rouge de nouveaux
variants qui pourrait être voilà plus
plus dangereux effectivement pour les
enfants n'est pas à l'abri en tout cas
non non on n'est pas à l'abri mais
plusieurs à des contaminations plus il y
aura des circulations plus des virus a
la possibilité des mutés donc plus vite
tandis qu on limite la prolifération bas
où on aura des chances de voir
apparaître des barioz est pour l'instant
et fort heureusement les vaccins type
arn messagers failles zero moderna on
montrait une efficacité pour des marion
et pas simplement
niveau des anticorps il ya aussi une
immunité cellulaire qui est activée et
pour l'instant l'efficacité est bonne
espérons que ça va continuer dans ce
sens là je voudrais juste rajouter
quelque chose je pense que comme nat et
la communication les parents je les vois
ça tous les jours aux urgences quand on
voit un patient ou en réanimation quand
on est impatients qui a 10 12 ans on ne
s'adresse pas simplement par an c'est
pas un objet c'est pas un être qu'on
ignore swan explique à l'emploi et bien
avant et je pense qu'à cet âge là
l'information doit être à donner aux
enfants parce que les enfants ont vécu
depuis plus d'un an
cette épidémie et section des êtres qui
ont une opinion qui ont une connaissance
de ce qu'ils vivent et subissent les
conséquences
je pense que toute campagne qui aurait
fait des bras cibler les enfants aussi
bien sur la connaissance sont en
formation mais également sa fierté
il ya dans l'histoire de la médecine une
campagne qui avait été fait aux états
unis il ya longtemps sur la rubéole
il avait fait un jeu de mots et c'était
la rubéole enbrel en fait c'est à dire
c'était le parapluie contre la rubéole
et il avait réussi à motiver les enfants
parce qu'il tirait une fierté et isabey
des des cartes des présentations et il
les enfants avaient été les moteurs pour
se faire vacciner pour un grand grand
pourcentage de la population parce
qu'ils avaient pris conscience qu'ils
avaient un rôle actif et qu'ils étaient
capables et des pensées et des décidé à
12 ans on n'est pas un petit enfant on a
une capacité plus encore quand on a 15
ou effectivement merci et ricardo
carbajal et pierre tattevin d'avoir
accepté ce débat en direct ce décryptage
en direct sur rt france